what would you say is the best horror
anime
in terms of like not in terms of
scariness but in terms of what the genre
has to offer entertainment yeah another
I don't even find another funny I'm not
about it [__] funny man holy [__]
those last two episodes are the last
episode oh my God that's the last two
words for the last two episodes of
another is a horror classic
I always recommend
um
what's a [__] cold in Japanese uh
cheeky
cheeky shiki's normally one I think he's
good yeah when they cry in English oh
Higurashi yeah yeah Hiroshi oh Higurashi
is good for the first two seasons and
then from season three just turns into a
slice of life
I mean I didn't actually finish a garage
I've only watched the first season which
is bad I know because all the answers
come in like the season too yeah I also
did a oopsie and watched it dubbed uh
which again which again
because the main character sounds just
like [__] Sonic I don't know why or
how they did that especially the
baseball bats huh why is everyone dying
yeah I don't know I I is there even a
good horror adamant I would say because
I personally love horror anime I'm gonna
google the top 10 horror I would say
personally it's a tie between one and
okay okay and magnetic Rose I've not
seen magnetos so huh not monologue not
princess
want to know if you can get [__] as
well okay
wait what's the top one okay
who made this list
oh God this is like Google's this is
Google's suggested okay okay
parasite no no no that's an action
anything with dubstep automatically is
disqualified from horror yeah another
yeah cheeky sure yeah devil man cry baby
which is
I definitely see the horror elements in
something like Attack on Titan and let's
say Tokyo not a promising start to the
list so this is IGN's Top 10 best horror
anime of all time and the picture they
chose to to you know show the list is a
[__] Death Note
because I died
the absolute state of Horrors top 10
best anime horror of all time it was
posted in October 2022 updated two
months ago two days ago let's see now
theater of Darkness
yeah yummy Shiba is actually like yeah
it's it's crazy
it's horror at least it's it's the queen
bee of horror you know what I mean
Tokyo Ghoul
[Music]
it's like a horror for like the first
five minutes and then it's just like
shown an action show yeah let's go devil
man cry baby accordingly sure number
seven Paranoia Agent
oh
I would I would like psychological but
yeah yeah six parasites no hi Jim what
do you want five Helsing
housing is more action no it's more
action yeah that was nothing to
horrified me about that oh perfect blue
yes yeah yeah I would actually say Yes
yes again more on the psychological
aspect I've never heard of this one
Boogie pop Phantom what about Phantom is
I wouldn't it's psychological I wouldn't
call that it's more of a thriller too
higgurashi yeah number one death number
death though is the best according to
IGN the best horror anime okay if anyone
ever says death note to me I'm like yeah
of course I know the best yeah I'm gonna
do that from now on high school's the
dead okay there's got to be a better run
okay so no no there isn't I've looked
into this because I'm like there must be
some good horror out of me and a lot of
times it's just it just doesn't exist
okay so legit like as someone who's seen
like all those on the list regardless of
if they're horror or not yeah like most
horror anime I would still say Mononoke
and magnetic gross like Mononoke is like
I feel Mononoke is what it would feel
like if they actually actually made a
good Junior adaptation where it's like
it has the same like subtleties and
quietness of junjito it's not
necessarily scary it's just super
[__] unsettling yeah because it's
like really quiet and really like no I
wouldn't say slow but it definitely
takes its time yeah and like the
concepts are really scary
um and the Magnetic Rose is like a short
film that was I think spearheaded by
Ultimo katsu here
um the creator of Akira but yeah it's
essentially think of perfect blue in
space
Akira and the concept of perfect blue in
space and you have magnetic growth it's
[__] awesome yeah and it's super
quick it's like it's like a 40 minute
short film but it's awesome okay heavily
highly recommend it if you like horror
yeah because yeah go for it I'm looking
I was on Twitter the other day and I saw
like a gif of like a really old Ash
anime I thought damn I'm sick which one
and so I went to the comments and they
were like oh no no don't watch it what
is it and then someone replied to them
being like this this anime is banned in
Norway for child pornography and I was
like because everyone watch it then
isn't it Midori it was kite
and that's also been adapted to uh
Samuel Jackson live-action film yeah
right it has yeah yeah I uh I had to
watch both when I did my review for kite
a while back up uh it's I can see why it
got banned back in the day because I
think it came out in the late 90s I
believe
um it was just like it was one of those
moments where I was like this looks cool
opens the replies oh God yeah uh it's uh
the anime so so the the anime is is
super short it's like two episodes or
something uh but it got banned in a lot
of countries because of that reason
um and then yeah I mean it's it's well
animated it's a really well animated
show and the concept is interesting but
just the execution it wasn't I had to
put yeah one scene in there yeah I mean
there's a there's a all ages version as
well um without the sex scene yeah but I
think it's the one with the sex scenes
that got banned oh okay because of those
reasons nice that they removed the one
without it and then for some [__]
reason Samuel Jackson was like I'ma turn
that into a live action was it actually
him who wanted to do it he's in it yeah
but I can't remember it wasn't I don't
know if it was like him like hey guys I
guess it's a great idea but they
literally heard that Samuel Jackson
likes hentai
and he's like yeah I don't think he
would like that hentai yeah but uh I had
to watch that as well for the review and
uh itch dog [__] it's really bad
um which won them both the live action
is the anime good the anime I think is
decent again it has a really interesting
concept so the the concept is that like
the the main girl has this weapon where
it's a gun but the bullets explode on
impact yeah that's what I shortly I sort
of give of that yeah yeah yeah solve
like the bullet going in and then they
explode and basically it's like the girl
looking for her uh basically it's like
the it's kind of like a Batman story of
like the girl's parents got killed by
this unknown organization yeah she's on
the hunt to like Kill The Killers yeah
um and so the concept is cool but it's
just like the ending is super [__]
weird again there's that like weird
problem with like the r18 version this
happens so often with stuff I like in
anime where I'm like this is sick and
then I just find out that it's like like
in a Golden Boy where we watched like a
few episodes ago yeah I love that show
and then I saw all the replies to the
comments being like yeah it's Shame
about the manga though and I was like
what do you what happened what happened
in the manga apparently he gets like the
[__] golden showered and like
kidnapped and just turned into a full-on
porno and I was like what the [__] what
the [__] of course it wasn't the anime I
watched why and then I'm like oh well
this thing looks cool it's like oh yeah
it's cool well you're a pedo now
you're a porn addict
now look I just want to watch I want to
watch some more like when I find stuff
that's old I'm like this looks cool and
I find out that like everything anime
that's cool and old is like all [__]
up it's like haha you lit you actually
watch porn which is surprisingly
accurate for a lot of especially older
shows yeah what was going on in the 90s
dude
the 90s OVA like era they were all
unhinged yeah there's so many shows
there were just so many shows that came
out in the 90s that were just like I
couldn't see why anime had this
underground kind of Aura around it
because you could just discover like
this grossly like yeah yeah like a lot
of it was like just an overabundance of
violence and Gore and like over
sexualized you know what's the best
horror anime
it's crazy how now it feels like like
everyone you know that you have like
redo of a Healer on that weird [__] in
anime and everyone's talking about how
like dude it's so [__] up it's so
gross it feels like damn I mean I feel
like we really [__] tamed down though
compared to what we they were releasing
I think video of a Healer is worse if
I'm being honest I think so I don't know
just like I don't know if it's because
it's like conceptually I will say
something to do with the art Styles now
because I weigh more like vibrant and
yeah like soft that it feels way I don't
know why when I watch this 90 [__] and
it's all grungy and it's all oh dude it
feels way grosser yeah yeah way like
worse even though weed over here's like
oh [__] it's also it's also because as
well like especially shows like you know
like genocyber or like violence Jack or
like any of the like really [__] gory
90s the problem is is yeah one it's less
saturated so it feels more like dark
it's always darker less vibrant yeah and
also they're way [__] better anime
has this one scene where it's like 120
frames per second guy's head exploding
and I'm like this is like
it's the first sick t-shirt
the reason why I think uh redo of healer
is worse is because you know viscerally
you know and I think the things that
happened in 90s ovas oh yes more [__]
up on paper but I feel like I don't know
I already know I'm just I mean yeah I
really realized yeah yeah I'm not I'm
not saying garbage you're [__] up but
like no no I the the thing the thing
that the big reason why I just couldn't
really get into video videos it was like
just
yeah he was just like the biggest this
is just obviously the most like Power
Trip yeah like Intel fantasy to that you
can get whereas I look at a lot of 90s
ovas and I was like yo these anime just
do some sick stuff yeah man yeah of
course it's [__] up of course it's
like hyper violent and [__] but holy
[__] someone was dedicated to that cross
oh yeah yeah definitely and in redo
vahila it's just like all right let's
just take the most incel power fancy you
can possibly get and uh of course you
know I don't really take it seriously
because it's just so far up that field
I'm just like I just don't it was so
comedic for me yeah yeah exactly right
just funny exactly right it just it just
I just could not take that [__]
seriously at all so what you're saying
is if read over healer was as well
animated as Gino cyber you would hate it
less
and what I'm saying is I would rather
redo the Healer just be a hentai then
pretend you know I I would rather just
be a Hands-On like genuine genuine well
you know at least like I I would
generally rather video just be its own
thing have a hentai how is it that if
breed over here was a hentai I'd feel
less guilty to watch it how does that
make sense because it pretends like it
has a plot yeah that's the thing right
that's it pretends like there's
character development and there is an
ongoing port line and that's the thing
that bothered me the most about redo of
a Healer it's like I was trying to watch
rants on like crunch
or just don't need don't like don't do
it at all don't do it at all